just that impact that looks great that
looks so freaking good for this movie
they did a lot of digital takeovers
whoa
yo this is cool is it another peter he's
16 years old it's another peter guy
thanks to grubhub for sponsoring this
episode stay tuned to the end to learn
about the grub hub guarantee
hey what's up welcome back to another
episode of visual effects status react
that's right you've seen the thumbnail
we're taking a look at luke skywalker
today because we have some thoughts we
did some videos last year about this
sort of thing in ilm honestly guys i
kind of feel like ilm did a bit of a mic
drop here so last year they had luke
skywalker up here in the mandalorian and
it's this moment in time where we're
seeing tv shows attempting visual
effects shots that were incredibly
challenging industry shattering effects
however the original luke skywalker was
like it was kind of a deep fake it was a
whole lot of compositing on top of that
and it felt very very stiff and a lot of
people had criticisms about how it
forced luke skywalker to be this like
very static character so lm's like i'm
playing basketball let me just work on
my dunks and then they
did this
oh look here's the thing i think the
scene is great i'm specifically not
going to watch this show but it's just
by itself this scene is awesome
[Music]
that looks great that looks so freaking
good
damn that's a face i love it it's like
here's like the most advanced recreation
of a human with this like alien puppet
those eyes opening those blinks flawless
blinks it looks quality man it looks so
good like i like it when they flex it's
almost like when they stop flexing when
they start being a little timid that it
starts like fade as a deep fake again
but like here it looks perfect so i'm
almost certain like 99 certain this is
purely a deep fake with maybe a touch of
compositing but i think it's much more
of a true deep fake than the original
luke skywalker from last year when they
eventually like kind of talked about the
deep fake they did it was like they kind
of technically did a deep fake but then
did a whole bunch of stuff on top of it
that is like frankenstein's monsters
does this even count as a deep fake
anymore whereas here you're saying that
you don't think there's any sort of like
cg stuff going on you think it's
legitimately just a deep fake yeah i'm
sure there's some compositing work going
on they're cleaning up the edges and
working the masks you know and all that
kind of stuff in terms of the face
unlike the last skywalker where it's
like here's the mouth here's the nose
and then we counted some eyes we counted
some wrinkles we can't like i think in
this case you're just looking at a good
deep fake in its purest form he once
said to me
size matters not
watching this on mute i personally think
it's almost flawless and the only reason
i say almost is because i know it's cg
yeah the only real criticism you can
make on this scene is the audio and the
lip sync because they tried to use an ai
voice synthesis to recreate his voice
the moment you hear the audio you're
like uh i feel like a voice actor would
have been a better
move it's it's i i hear what you're
saying i still feel like it's all right
but also i do think the lips themselves
are still a little on the stiff side but
it's really cool to see them emoting
like if you're gonna bring a character
back ideally they can emote and you see
moding and it's super cool you know you
can get full expressions
like that with a deep fake you can be
looking around a little bit all that
stuff works really well and the more you
do that the more you express the more
you're looking around and moving your
face and you're seeing wrinkles move and
you're seeing lighting move around the
face more that happens the more it
marries it into the scene you know i
know a bit about deep fakes but i
haven't done them as extensively as you
guys have and when i see that shot here
i look at the eyes and see how the
lighting in the eyes and the reflections
really match the scene in the lighting
and lighting direction and i know in the
past dpx usually have a problem with
that and so i'm wondering
what your guys thoughts on that process
would be if that is part of the deep
fake or maybe that was an additional
pass in my experience doing deep fakes
the eyes are always like the worst part
followed by the mouth it is possible
that they could have just done some
freaking cgi's to put over the deep fake
ilm is fully capable of making the eyes
look incredible a defect grabs its
lighting from the underlying face so as
long as the underlying face is lit
correctly the deep fake will be lit
correctly in terms of like the
highlights in the eyes specifically that
can become a little bit more you know
iffy but that's an easy enough thing
just to composite it whether you're
cleaning up the eyes and making a little
bit crisper and clear or just even
putting a highlight into the eyes feel
the force all around you
so something that stands out to me here
is that not a bad weight necessarily but
they're being very very careful with the
deep fake there's no direct sunlight on
his face ever there's no shadows being
cast on his face because when you have
like patterns of shadows in the face
that becomes very very difficult to
reproduce the deep fake you know the
sunlight is kind of behind and above but
even so like you know you're not getting
any splash of light on his cheeks you're
specifically talking about dappled
lighting on his face yes you're right i
didn't even think about that that would
confuse the hell out of a deep fake
program yeah t-fakes can kind of do like
shadow patterns on your face but in no
way is it going to hold up at the level
it would need to hold up for this show
this is what indicates to me that this
is a deep fake is because they are
avoiding every single weak spot of deep
fakes and focusing on the strengths but
also notice how when the lighting
becomes kind of this flat frontal
lighting here it starts to feel a little
bit more like it's a video of mark
hamill's face pasted onto the footage
just a little bit it has that feeling
whether it's like shadows under his nose
and in his mouth being a bit of a
different feel than like the dark of his
jacket or things having a just a touch
of grain or sharpness or the lighting
not quite being exact you can't really
put your finger on it and it's
interesting because it has a different
look like we can really spot cgi we can
spot like 3d models they just have a
certain look to them right and we can
really spot when something's composited
the way that the lighting doesn't quite
match sometimes or shadows aren't quite
playing or edges are not quite blended
but deep fakes and other ai generated
imagery has this weird like
pseudo-painterly look it's almost as if
like the best photo real painter in the
world was just going there just busting
out frames as fast as they could and
you're like this looks really good
it looks painterly but it's not painted
what is it and i just i really like that
we're entering this new generation of
visual effects that has a completely
different look from the cgi the models
and miniatures and the photographs and
the painting that we've been used to for
years and now it's this deep
gi dgi deep generated imagery generative
art generator generative art because
it's like it's being generated it's
literally a computer painting i guess
it's technically still cgi but cgi up
until this point has always referred to
3d models and now we're getting into cgi
computer generated imagery is generated
through neural networks can you go to
our deep fake and i've been staring at
this like perfect flawless high level
ilm deep fake i just want to see how
ours looks in comparison now
it looks like vegan it is very square
drawn and long necked it's got dean's
posture but i'm looking at luke the face
itself is not that far off in fidelity
from the luke skywalker that they have
like that right there
pretty much actually right on par with
it if i'm gonna be frank
we're having a look at just this part
though you know it's like the hair is
all weird there's a lot of necks showing
and you know it's like the face shape is
different those are the constraints that
we literally can't get around and we're
just doing what we can but the thing
that we can do here is the face and you
know what i kind of agree it does still
hold up you know what we weren't that
far off i'm proud of our work and not
bad good work but disney's now made a
better cgi luke skywalker to the people
that think that deep fakes are like a
threat to the truthfulness of media i
just want to point out visual effects
have been around for a long time
deep fakes are just a very tiny part of
an overall world where we can fake
whatever we want so i wouldn't worry
about it or i mean just follow my rule
which is you know anything you see on a
screen assume it's not real
[Laughter]
i mean that's a good rule too honestly
skepticism
in time
you will help them
accomplish wonders
we're going to look at some effect shots
that i took from the comments of a video
recommending we look at man of steel
have we looked at this yeah i don't
think we've looked at this scene i
honestly don't think we've looked at
anything from management that's crazy i
know so much stuff in here it's not
crazy
the craft he arrived in
where is it so i'm super happy we're
finally watching this sequence because
it marks the beginning of a huge
hollywood trend also those suits not
real okay well yeah so yeah you really
diminished the impact
i mean
this is what i'm saying these suits look
amazing and what this was 2013 or 2013.
yeah like this is what for me anyways
when it's a regular thing to just have
your actors walk around in mocap suits
and figure out the costumes later we saw
that in many many films since then but
this is one of those first movies of all
right here's a huge budget movie
millions of dollars being spent on it
like what are the bad guys going to look
like well slap these pjs on and our whiz
kids in the back are going to make a
dope costume for you no no
man what are our villains going to look
like it's like oh i guess we'll just go
to quarter digital.store and hook them
up
there it is
i hope our mocap sweaters are in stock
for this movie they did a lot of digital
takeovers they would film for real in
one shot and they would know and that
they're gonna whip the camera over here
and move to this spot and it would have
to be digi doubles between them on top
of a digi environment to make it all
work they had this rig i think they
called it the shandy camera it was
essentially a pipe with six cameras on
it they would have superman like go
through his poses and they would take
pictures for actual animation keyframes
and so they can kind of see it from a
few different angles and so when they
recreated the 3d geometry for superman
they could project that onto him from
various angles to help with the
transitions but they also brought out
this crazy camera rig that would capture
these super high-res hdris essentially
they also had a very high quality lidar
scan of the entire set and each of those
times that they would create these super
high quality hdrs they would project
that onto the geometry and you would end
up with two and a half d projections of
the entire town and so they were able to
basically line up one shot inside of
that whole 3d town and then whip the
camera over to the next shot and because
everything is in the correct spot and
looking realistic enough it just works
just that impact something that i've
noticed
that works really well here is the
animation the animation for the
characters is very good because they
take correct account of momentum and
mass i see this a lot in movies where
someone will jump and their upward speed
won't really be fast enough to warrant
how far they go and you end up with
people like doing like these weird runny
things because they're trying to merge
it with how we always used to do it
which was on wires you have a person
being lifted up but when you're being
lifted up by wires you cannot go at the
speed you would have to go if you were
to jump 100 feet in the air the sense of
speed is really nice and up until they
could do 3d doubles there wasn't any way
to really accurately show what a
powerful punch would look like and how
you'd react to that because for your
actors with that speed they'd
break their necks and get concussions so
they can do 3d models you can actually
see how hard a hit would look like that
throw like that's a real
speed you need to throw somebody at
i do like the way that van crumples in
the back when he throws it yeah like he
grabs it it crumples and then when he
throws it it crumples again i just i
like how this movie really preserves a
lot of those realistic types of motion
because they obey the laws of physics
but that's hand animated artists had to
manually make sure that all of that
stuff was working realistically yeah no
i can't stop thinking about it like
every time i see a superhero get slammed
into wall and they're like oh it's like
wait hold on y'all were you just going
like 200 miles an hour
like you're gonna go through that wall
like that
so the suggestion for looking at man of
steel actually came directly from a
comment so if you have ideas for other
stuff for us to look at leave a comment
we'll look at it
background wait wait you guys haven't
heard of the back rooms i somehow missed
this they got 16 million views in the
last month it says in parentheses found
footage so what you're about to show us
is entirely real
100
just hit play
[Music]
hello
oh it's one of these types of videos
there's a whole genre of like horror
short films on youtube which is like
this concept of like strange office
industrial spaces and like walkthroughs
of them and there's this weird
surrealist horror quality to them i love
it personally they've definitely nailed
the vhs look
hello someone was there
[Music]
it'd be cool if this is entirely cg
because it wouldn't be that hard to do
it's fairly simple geometry and
texturing and then you throw a giant vhs
gloss over it so you guys have probably
figured out that this is obviously 100
cg was this rendered in a game engine
because all the other ones i've seen are
usually in game engines this is all done
in blender actually okay really okay i
i'm gonna say that there's key frame
animation and plug-ins to make it appear
like it's handheld this doesn't feel
like it's keyframed it could be but that
would be a lot of work i think the
camera is some handheld motion mixed
with animated with like a noise modifier
like those little bumps from the steps
that's really hard to keyframe and just
you won't really get that with the noise
modifiers that's probably you know real
footage i feel like it'd be faster just
to pull up cam track ar in your phone
and then just grab the camera path so
someone is actually moving around with
the camera going through the exact same
sort of motion that you're seeing here
it's just you're not seeing any of the
footage you're seeing the track camera
rendered in a scene
[Music]
yo i saw hot dog man hey hot dog man
doesn't make that noise
whoa
yo this is cool we got the freaking
infinity hallways i'm super down with
this kind of stuff this is super cool
and airy so one of the reasons this
looks so photoreal is because this is
the kind of lighting environment that a
lot of cgi technology has advanced
towards being able to replicate well
it's basic environments it's also not a
whole lot of really complicated
materials you're looking at basically
paint wallpaper glossy wooden floors
that kind of thing with small light
sources and it's all about calculating
the global illumination how that light
bounces around things the other thing is
you know imperfections are really
important to make stuff like photo real
and if you had these big environments
it'd be really hard to go through and do
all the detailed little imperfections to
make it look real so this is a situation
where you slap that vhs filter on top
and then suddenly all those
imperfections are just there because
it's just noise and grain on top of the
screen and all the little details become
hard to see and hard to read kane
parsons i think it's the name of the kid
who made this
child
child wait really the boy is it another
peter he's 16 years old it's another
peter god
it blows my mind the sort of things that
like people can just do for free these
days like a 16 year old made all of this
stuff using free resources the most
expensive aspect of this whole thing was
probably his cell phone
yeah like honestly and the thing is is
this isn't actually that hard to do like
if you're just starting out you want to
try something in blender make a giant
surrealist office building like this
like it's all right angles you know
simple light sources it plays
towards the strengths of a new user this
is cool this is like this great
intersection of like video games and
filmmaking it's super surreal it's super
moody and creepy and it makes me want to
play the game version of this kudos to
you kane if you're not one of the 16
million people that's already seen it
cane pixels on youtube i'll link in the
description below
i must admit they gave me chills
alright so we're done shooting react for
the day but we are like so busy with so
many videos happening all at the same
time i love being able to one wheel out
to lunch but i literally don't have time
lately or especially today so i'm just
gonna order some stuff on today's
sponsor grubhub i am like so hungry
right now what are you feeling dude i'm
feeling burgers burger time burger time
could be here in 25 minutes now grubhub
has a guarantee that your food will be
there on time and i'm going to test that
they say it's gonna be here in 30
minutes well burger time is in the next
30 minutes okay it took me a minute to
actually put in my order there's now 205
the clock is ticking and it should be
here in 30 minutes and this is great
because now that means that i can
actually crank through some stuff here
while i'm a little hangry but you know
what hangry productivity is still
productivity
[Music]
hungry almost burgers
[Music]
wow dude it's here i should have left
the food at the door
alrighty
is it there yeah look at that
look at that
it is
225.
they were fast hey but it's a grubhub
guarantee what can i say time to eat
with the grubhub guarantee at home
dining is carefree and affordable if you
want to get that grubhub experience
yourself go ahead and click the link in
the description and thanks again to
grubhub for sponsoring this video oh i
hate the paper
oh my god
back to the episode thank you so much
for joining us on this episode of visual
effects artist react hope to see you
next saturday and hey consider
subscribing if you don't miss a single
video because we upload other videos
besides special effects rs react they
generally come out on sunday so let's
pretend let's pretend it's a mystery and
the only way you'd know is if you
subscribe and 42 percent of you guys
know michael come on michael subscribe
it's you've watched like 20 of our
videos now no i see you there gorbachev
hey into the one zonkey that's out there
what's up zonkey
all right that's it thanks for joining
us we'll see you guys in the next one